we are aware that we can look for life
in other places
other places in our solar system and of
course on the exoplanets around other
stars and uh within 10 or 20 years
i think two things could happen which
would be really really important we
might
with the next big telescope
be able to image some of the earth-like
planets around other stars
image right get a picture well i
actually let me caveat that it takes 50
years to get a resolved image but but
but try to detect the light because now
of course
these exoplanets are detected by their
effects on the parent star they either
cause their parents start to dim
slightly when they transit across in
front of it and so we see the dips or uh
their gravitational pull makes the star
wobble a bit so most of the the five
thousand plus planets that have been
found
around other stars they've been found
indirectly by their effects yes in one
of those two ways on the people could
still do a pretty good job of estimating
size
all those kinds of subjects the size and
the mass you can estimate um
detecting the the actual light from
one of these exoplanets hasn't really
built on yet exactly one or two very
very very bright big planets so maybe
like james webb telescope well james
webb
may do this but even better will be
the european ground-based telescope
called unimaginative to the extremely
large telescope which has a 39 meter
diameter mirror 39 meters yeah mosaic of
800 sheets of glass and that will
collect enough light
from
one of these exoplanets
around the nearby star um to be able to
separate out its light from that of the
star which is a millions of times
brighter and get the spectrum of the
planet
and see if it's got oxygen or
chlorophyll and things in it so that
that will come um james webb may may
make some some steps there um but
i think we can look forward to learning
quite a bit um in the next 20 years
because i like to say um supposing that
the aliens looking at the solar system
then they see the sun as an ordinary
star they see the earth
as in carl sagan's eyes praise a pale
blue dot
lying very close in the
sky to its star our sun and much much
much fainter but if they could observe
that dot they could learn quite a bit
they could
perhaps get the specialty of the light
and find the atmosphere
they'd find the shade of blue was
slightly different depending on whether
the pacific ocean or land massive asia
was facing them so they could infer the
length of the day and the oceans and
continents and maybe something about the
seasons and the climate
and uh that's the kind of
calculation calculation and uh inference
we might be able to draw within the next
10 or 20 years about other exoplanets
and um
and evidence of some sort of
biosphere on one of them would of course
be crucial and it would rule out the uh
logical possibilities that life is
unique but there's another way in which
this may happen in the next 20 years
people think there could be something
swimming under the ice of uh europa and
enceladus and probes are being sent
to maybe not quite go under the ice but
detect the spray coming coming out to
see if there's evidence for organics in
that and
if we found any evidence for
an origin of life that had happened
in either those places that would
immediately be important because if life
has originated twice
independently in one planetary system
the solar system that would tell us
straight away it wasn't a rare accident
and must have happened billions of times
in the galaxy
at the moment
we can't rule out it being unique and
incidentally if we found life on mars
then that would still be ambiguous
because uh um people have realized that
this early life could have got from mars
to earth or vice versa on meteorites so
um if you found life on mars then some
skeptics could still say if it's a
single origin um but i think europa is
far enough that's far enough away yeah
because
so so that's why that would be
especially it's always the skeptics
that ruin a good party but
but we need them of course we need them
at the party we need some skeptics at
the party yeah um but boy would that be
so exciting to find life
on one of the moons yes
of course
that'll just be any kind of vegetation
or life um the question of the
aliens of science fiction is a different
matter
you